FOEGELE ELEVATING WITH ZACH WHAE
STARTING TO I CAN UP IN THIS
CROSS ICE SAUCE TO MCDAVID.
NUMBER 896MONTON EARLIER ON.
THIS PUCK IS UP FOR DRAISAITL.
WALKS IN, A SHOT BLOCKED.
WHAT A RECOVERY BY GUDAS.
ST SHIFT?
LUOSTARINEN CLEARS AGAIN.IT'S H.
MCDAVID BREAKING THROUGH, AND A.
20 SECONDS OILERS.
NONE MORE DANGEROUS
BARKOV 15 GOALS IN THE 26 GAMES
HE'S PLAYE WIDE.
REBOUND OFF THE PLEXI,BLE HOW ME
CAN GET ON THAT SHOT.
BUT THIS IS A BEAUTIFUL PASS BYD
RIGHT POSITION.MIKKO
BUT WATCH VERHAEGHE.
HE STOPS.
EVERYB IN BY GUDAS.
WE ARE PAST THE MIDWAY POINT OF
THEY'RE ALL OVER IT.
FOEGELE TAKES IT BEHI LEARNS.
GETS IT IN DEEP.
SCEVIOUR PUMPED UP BEHIND THE
SN
FROM BENSON.
ONE EXTRA
PASS INTENDED FOR
CLEAR OF VERHAEGHE.
AND BARKOV WILL SMACK UNIVERSITY
OF NORTH DAKOTA.
COLTON SCEVIOUR FIRES ONE UP TH.
AND LOFTED UP ICE BY BOUCHARD.
WE DIDN'T KNOW HE WOULD BE BACK
INTO THE G
AND MAYBE ONE THAT FOR KOSKINEN
JUST DIDN'T PIC>> Jack: BARKOV S
WAY TO A
DE THERE WITH RYAN,
CECI, AND NURSE.
AND DUCLAIR JUST STAYS IN THE
BATTLE.IGH AND
WIDE.
TIPPETT WINDS IT AROUND TO
LUNDELL. THE
GAME, BOBROVSKY ANOTHER HOT
GOALIE TWO GAMES IN A ROW GUDAS.
HE HAS BEEN THE SCOIR TONIGHT.
I MEAN NOT THE FIVE GOALS.
IT'S BO
COME.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S BROKEN UP.
A GREAT JOB BY TIPPETT TO STAY